The position GL_Position, and the color vColor, were generated by the vertex
shader. These are passed on to the rasterizer, which interpolates these across
the triangle and creates fragments. Each fragment is then passed through the
fragment shader. You'll be happy to hear this shader is very simple. All this
shader does is takes the interpolated color, vColor, and copies it over to
gl_FragColor, the built-in output variable for what color appears on the
screen. The fourth coordinate is set to the alpha value, which says how solid
the surface is. This is normally 1. Notice how the language elegantly
understands vectors. VColor is a vector with three coordinates. We construct
the gl_FragColor, a four-element vector, by using vColor and appending a
number. GLSL knows what this means. In general, the language is very aware of
common vector and scalar operations. Here's another example of vector
operations. Say we have an input specular color and a specular amount. We've
computed a value for the specular variable, how much it should affect the
fragment's color. In this line of code we multiply this variable, a single
floating point number, by a vector with three elements. We add this to the
fragment color by specifying which components we want changed. Here the R, G,
and B components are modified. The component names for the 4 elements are XYZW
for points and vectors, RGBA for colors, and STPQ for texture coordinates. S
and T are sort of like U and V. I won't go into all the features of the
language, see the additional course materials for full references. One thing
worth mentioning is that there all sorts of built-in functions. Some you'll
probably be familiar with, such as absolute value, sign, power, and square
root. Others are more specific to graphic, such as normalize, dot, cross
product, and reflect. For debugging shader code, the browser's debug console
can often give useful errors. For example, in this line of code, I put a
representation for a floating point number that's perfectly valid in C, but is
not part of the GLSL language, so it was flagged here. Sometimes the errors are
a bit cryptic. In this case the 0 should be 0.0. GLSL is very picky about
having a floating point number have a decimal point. In either case, you'll get
a blank screen or not much warning otherwise. I sometimes found myself adding a
line or two at a time and seeing if everything stays on the screen. If not, I
comment out the lines until my scene reappears. I call this binary search
debugging.